je suis devant les superbes lampes qui
sont exposées au musée de la ville dans
le cadre de l'exposition plastique pl
mais c'est sur une autre exposition
qu'on va demander à la directrice de ce
musée de nous éclairer l'exposition
consacrée au street art Marie laurestig
bonjour vous êtes la la directrice du
musée de la ville à
Saint-Quentin on est là dans une
exposition qui Consac qui s'appelle
plastique plastock consacré au
plastiques on va en parler tout à
l'heure mais il y a aussi à l'étage en
dessous une exposition qui est consacrée
au street art l'art de la rue qui est
née un peu en même temps que que la
ville de Saint-Quentin c'est ça elle est
née oui peut-être une dizaine d'années
plus tard parce qu'en fait c'est plutôt
il y a 30 ans 50 an ontime à 4
et et le Stre plutôt il y a 30 ans
notamment avec les BL Blur alors streart
c'est à la fois le hip hop c'est à la
fois le grave c'est à la fois même le
skate
ENF comment on explique au fond une
ville nouvelle se développe en même
temps que se développent des des arts
nouveaux alors d'abord je pense que tous
ces arts de street art effectivement ils
ont une première vocation qui est la
cohésion ent entre les gens alors quand
black blamber a commencé ils on été
black blber c'est le Hipop he le Hipop
ils ont commencé avec la pasque qui
était une association par municipale
enfin municipale et ils ont travaillé
avec des jeunes et ils ont commencé à
créer des concours de danse et cetera et
après ils sont devenus une association
qui a eu ce rayonnement international
qu' qu'on a prett notamment avec Jean
gemmad qui est présent dans
l'exposition et en fait oui tout le
streetart c'est la cohésion c'estàdire
que aujourd'hui ils investissent le
territoire alors que ce ce soit avec des
skates avec des BMX ou avec ce qu'on
appelle le foot de rue ou le golf de rue
que ce soit avec les grafes les pochoirs
les tags et cetera et ils vont aller
dans sur le territoire marquer leur
empreinte partout et aujourd'hui ils ont
besoin d'un territoire neuf avec alors
les skates ils vous diront qu'ils ont
besoin de béton hein que sans béton on
pe c'est très bien une jolie plage mais
c'est pas
possible voilà c'est pas le truc idem
pour les pour les graffeurs ils ont
besoin de surface Liss sur lequel ils
vont pouvoir exprimer leur talent et un
mur avec a plein de petits rehaau et
cetera ça les intéresse pas ils ont
besoin de surface lisse de surface béton
et notamment de lieux de passage on voit
bien que les fresques c'est sous les
tunnels le long des le long des voie de
chemin de fer et cetera c'est sur les
sur vos m vous avez plutôt un petit tag
ou une petite signature mais pas une
belle fresque voilà donc la ville se
prête à ça la ville se prête à ça et en
même temps ce que vous disiez c'est un
c'est un arc qui se crée de lui-même
c'est pas un AR qui vient alors il y a
il y a les deux deux choses he dans dans
une ville nouvelle on le voit bien à
Saint-Quentin il y a euh une volonté
politique de créer des lieux culturels
on est à côté du du théâtre qui est une
scène nationale et puis il y a une prise
en main des gens par eux-mêmes et au
fond le street art c'est ça le streetart
c'est ça oui et c'est une prise en main
des gens par eux-mêmes qui aujourd'hui
n'arrivent pas à trouver un
écho dans les bonslieux notamment on VO
bien alors on voit bien qu'à Paris le
street art aujourd'hui c'est c'est
devenu un phénomène de mode alors on a
eu la Tour 13 on a un certain nombre de
choses même un peu récupéré pardon c'est
même un peu
complètement récupéré euh dans dans les
salles de ventes le Street se vent
extrêmement bien ça se vent très bien et
le phénomène aujourd'hui dans les villes
c'est que les gens vont carrément casser
les murs pour récupérer les morceaux de
de Graf ou de ou de ou de fresque parce
que peut-être qu'un jour l'artiste qui a
fait ça aura une côte peut-être
peut-être une chance de s'enrichir voilà
aujourd'hui les pouvoirs publics dans
les quand on n'est pas dans Paris pas
dans les capitales ont beaucoup de mal à
prendre ça on a plutôt tendance à voir
dans tous ces jeunes qui vont faire qui
sont qui travaillent dans les cultures
urbaines avoir des comment dirais-je des
pas de la racaille parce que just G qui
salissent les choses qui cuent qui
s'anissent qui investissent des des
lieux qui sont qui le sont pas destinés
et donc aujourd'hui je pense qu'aussi le
fait de faire une exposition comme ça
c'est d'essayer de voir comment est-ce
que les institutions peuvent rencontrer
des gens qui sont dans des des cultures
underground dans des cultures parallèles
et comment est-ce qu'on peut réussir à
les mettre dans un lieu au même endroit
et ça c'est intéressant parce que donc
c'est c'est vraiment une démarche qu'on
a eu on a travaillé avec des jeunes
d'ici on a travaillé avec les anciens
donc comme Jean Jeban mais on a
travaillé aussi avec beaucoup de jeunes
aujourd'hui et le résultat c'est qu'on
voit venir au musée des gens qui sont
jamais venus mais on voit je sais pas si
vous les avez vu en rentrant on avait là
plusieurs jeunes avec sous bras
justement jamais vu justement il y a
deux questions alors est-ce que d'une
part c'est pas de la puis que vous
appelez musée après tout on parlera
après de la fonction de ce musée et puis
de son originalité mais vous fait mus
est-ce que c'est pas une sorte de
récupération par les institutions dont
vous PE partie d'un art qui qui lui a
échappé non c'est pas une récupération
parce qu'on n' pas fait une exposition
d'art là aujourd'hui hein euh on est
dans une exposition plutôt de société
c'est-à-dire qu'on explique ce que c'est
que que le street art on explique un
certain nombre de choses on a d'ailleurs
toute une partie qui montre à quel point
ça coûte cher à la collectivité hein le
prix de de nettoyage d'un m Carr de tag
il est relativement évé tout ça c'est
c'est dedans on a des vidéos qui
montrent comment on va dégrafer euh ou
détaguer un certain nombre de surfaces à
quel point le le mur du théâtre a été
abîmé à une certaine époque donc nonous
on n'est pas on n'est pas complaisant
hein faut pas on n absolument pas
compllaisant pas récupérateur montrez
montrez un phénomène au f on montre un
phénomène et on essaie de dialoguer avec
avec tous ces jeunes qui je pense ont
apprécié le dialogue qu'on avait avec
eux on leur a donné un peu aussi à
certains une certaine forme de carartte
blanche et on arrivé avec des photos
avec des graphes avec des tags et cetera
on a pris ou on a pas pris parce que
c'est aussi notre rôle aujourd'hui d'êt
discriminant de dire ça oui ça non et
aujourd'hui ça fonctionne plutôt bien je
pense pas qu'on est dans la récupération
on est vraiment dans plutôt une étude de
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans la
ville et c'est notre rôle alors voilà
j'avais une question mais c'est vous
couperz un peu l'herbe sous le pied de
cette question parce que c'est dans un
musée donc on pourrait se dire c'est de
l'art est-ce que exposer un un roller
est-ce que c'est de l'art exposer un
t-shirt est-ce que c'est de l'art mais
vous me dites que c'est pas votre but
alors nous on n'est pas un musée de
beauard il y a plusieurs catégories de
musées nous on est typiquement pas un
musée de beauard on a un un musée ce
qu'on appelle de société c'està direire
qu'on va travailler sur
l'évolution duun d'un microocod
nous on travaille sur C et on a
effectivement notre rôle c'est de
comprendre comment l'espace de 40 ans 70
2010 ou à peu près ce territoire qui
était un territoire agricole est devenu
un territoire uneille urbain alors
effectivement on travaille sur
l'architecture l'art publicique et
cetera ce que fait ce qu'on fait
classiquement sur la ville si vous
voulez mais on travaille aussi sur
l'aventure urbaine c'estd ce que sont
les gens comment est-ce qu'ils vivent
dans ce territoire comment ils se
l'approprient et nous on a aussi comme
rôle de passer
l'image de ce territoire aux gens on a
un rôle de médiateur comment est-ce que
les gens peuvent s'approprier un lieu
qui a un vrai potentiel patrimonial dire
qu'on a des grands architectes des
grands artistes un urbanisme assez
étonnant assez unique on a comme mission
de pass c'est réussi ouais c'est
d'ailleurs la vie nouvelle la plus
réussie he probablement la plus réuss
oui ououi
certainement on a donc cette mission de
passer de transmettre et c'est ça le
rôle du é c'est pas de de mettre en
évidence de l'art c'est de dire aux gens
voilà vous habitez dans un territoire
qui est
particulier qui est un peu étonnant
peut-être pour vous mais il est
particulier et qui est en lui en
lui-même patrimonial alors vous parliez
des des pionniers de de cet art Jean
gemad alors toujours à la tête de de
Black blomber mais qu'est-ce qui est-ce
qu'on est-ce qu'il y a des noms comme ça
on sait ce que sont devenus ces gens qui
étaient qui étaient parmi les premiers à
à faire soit le hip hop soit les grafes
soit les soit les tag pas très bien en
fait alors en fait c'est c'est c'est
c'est un des une des choses qui est un
petit peu dommage sur ce territoire
c'est que quand on a des des des gens
qui commencent à avoir une vraie
carrière on les voit he tous les
trapistes souvent ils s'en vont il s'en
vont ils s'en vont alors est-ce que
c'est parce queon leur donne pas les
moyens de s'exprimer est-ce que ça c'est
pas moi qui vais avoir ce je ne sais pas
mais c'est vrai qu'ils s'en vont euh ils
s'en vont ils restent pas on a eu des
graffeurs j'ai j'ai oublié le nom assez
assez importants ils sont partis en
Belgique euh on sait pas le retenir oui
c'est un peu dommage ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui il faut aussi se poser la
question peut-être de comment est-ce que
de territoire un peu original on devient
un véritable territoire de création et
comment est-ce qu'on conserve cette
création mais c'est pas le rôle du musée
aujourd'hui hein nous il est de de faire
de transmettre l'histoire et pour
revenir donc au Hipop à on le sent
parfois qu' se plaint justement de pas
avoir eu peut-être la
reconnaissance qu'il aurait qu'il aurait
pu avoir parce qu'il était un des
pionniers de cette culture là est-ce que
vous avez senti ça aussi chez
gensl c'est pas un connaissance ou le ou
l'aide ou enfin voilà oui c'est pas non
parce que je pense que Jean jment il est
pas mal aidé par par la Communauté
d'Agglomération hein nous on travaille
avec lui mais pas seulement euh mais je
pense que c'est c'est c'est assez
général c'est aussi des cultures qui se
trouvent assez mal dans un théâtre c'est
pas facile hein quand on fait du hiphop
c'est un art de rue et dès qu'on le
transfère dans un théâtre l'impression
qu'on donne est pas la même idem pour le
grap nous on a un grand grap qui est en
bas grande fraesse elle a pas la même
vocation dans un musée que que à
l'extérieur alors on a des graffeurs qui
gentiment nous l'ont fait et qui en font
régulièrement pendant les ateliers c'est
pas la même chose ça a pas la même
signification le graffeur quand il la
met dans la rue il y a un message
derrière quand il la met au musée le
message disparaît donc c'est
auss vous disiez c'est vrai il y a
beaucoup de jeunes qui viennent C
exposition est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'ils
apprennent en voyant des t-shirts ou des
des roll alors je pense que que ils
savent pas tous d'abord ils se
connaissent pas tous entre des bombes à
peinture enfin ils se connaissent pas
tous entre
eux ils connaissent pas tous non plus
l'histoire de ce territoire donc en fait
dans cette exposition on a essayé de
faire dialoguer hier et aujourd'hui
c'est ce qu'on fait classiquement dans
le musée hein c'est toujours de faire
dialoguer l'ancien et et le futur c'est
c'est notre mission donc en fait ils
vont découvrir aussi les anciennes
générations vous savez on a filmé des
des jeunes à la BU en train de danser
qui fais du Crump je suis pas sûr que
jeanéal ça lui parle aujourd'hui et en
même temps c'est important que queils
sacheent que sur ce territoire il y avit
une vraie histoire qui sont pas les
premiers il sont pas les pionniers il y
en a eu voilà donc ils vont découvrir un
certain nombre de choses il y a pas mal
de films aussi he les t-shirts sont là
mais il y a beaucoup de films qui ont
été tournés çacoup cétait c'est un peu
la question qui F mais
oui alors on est justement dans au sein
de cette exposition alors qui était
consacré au plastique plastique et Plast
on va peut-être parler un peu des des
des de ce qu'on peut y voir mais ça
m'amène vous poser la question vous en
parliez justement sur la vocation de ce
ce musée de la ville notre métier
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
euh l'évolution de la société en milieu
urbain et le plastique en fait euh en
fait partie la prochaine exposition
qu'on va faire celle qu'on est en train
de monter pour septembre prochain elle
est sur entre guillemets ce qu'on
appelle les salles de bain on appelle ça
salle de bain c'est voir comment les
politiques d'hygiène santé depuis les
années 30 ou à peu près ont radicalement
modifier notre rapport alors au corps
évidemment mais aussi à l'architecture
c'estàd que la place de la de bain qui
éit inexistante dans les années elle est
absolument énorme au design parce que le
Design la Déco dans les salles de bain
est extrêmement importante et à toute la
communication qu'il y a autour la la
publicité les objets qu'on va trouver
les produits cosmétiques et cetera et là
alors ce sont des objets en plastique
que vous avez trouvé sur le territoire
alors pas tous il y en a un certain
nombre oui qu'on a trouvé sur le
territoire on fait des appels à collecte
d'ailleurs pour les salles de bain ceux
qui ve don des choses si vous avez des
des choses voilà je fais un appel contac
le
musée par exemple alors on est on est
proche du design quand même on est pas
proche du design on est sur des grands
design là on s'est mis à l'endroit où on
a on a des grands designers qui sont ici
mais pas tout on a par exemple derrière
vous il y a un téléphone Orange on a un
salon de poupée Barbie oui ça c'est des
dons de gens du territoire et d'ailleurs
je m'amuse souvent à dire que ce musée
on devrait l'appeler le musée sous
l'escalier parce que oui parce qu'il est
sous l'escalier du théâtre on est sous
l'escalier du théâtre et souvent les
gens retrouvent sous leur propre
escalier des choses qu'ils avaient gardé
et donc ils se disent ah je sais pas si
j'en ai besoin mais peut-être que pour
le musée ce serait intéressant voilà
donc voilà ça c'est l'appel qu'il faut
faire voilà l'escalier donc donc si vous
avez des objets dont vous pensez qu'
peuvent avoir un intérêt sociologique ou
esthétique il faut vous contacter
contacter le musée de la ville et puis
en attendant bah venez voir l'exposition
sur le street art merci infiniment je
remci
beaucoup